[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité tout
d'abord bien sûr la france qui a rendu
hommage à samuel pas cuit ce professeur
d'histoire victime d'un attentat
offensante honorine vous verrez des
manifestations ont eu lieu dans de
nombreuses villes un peu partout en
france
du nouveau sur le plan sanitaire des
tests plus rapide arrivent sur le
territoire
nous irons donc en occitanie nous ils
sont expérimentés marche-t-il c'est ce
que nous verrons dans un instant voilà
nous commençons ce journal comme je vous
le disais dans les titres par le choc
provoqué par la mort de samuel pâtit ce
prof d'histoire de conflans sainte
honorine qui a été victime d' un ignoble
attentat
de retour de son collège où il exerçait
son métier
un hommage national lui a été rendu par
le président de la république à la
sorbonne la france entière s'est
mobilisée dans la rue comme vous le
voyez sur ces images tournées par nos
confrères des télévisions locales un peu
partout à conflans à paris bien sûr à
epinal au mans à abbeville dans la loire
une mobilisation générale contre ce
crime odieux
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions recueillies par nos confrères
de tv bocal la chaîne des quartiers
parisiens regardent ça horrible
je sais pas quoi dire d'autre a pas de
mots pour dire ça c'est monstrueux
j'ai pas de mots pour ce qui s'est passé
depuis que ça s'est passé je je retrouve
des proches mais je peux pas m'exprimer
ritchie bros dans un centre de formation
d'apprentis
je parle à des caricatures le
pratiquement le même jour que samuel et
les mômes
j'ai des musulmans j'ai des chrétiens
des athées tout ça ça passe depuis le
temps aucun ministre ne fait quoi que ce
soit dire qu'on met on met la poussière
sous le tapis et
et on attend 15 francs soit tué ou king
directrice d'école se suicide c'est
l'universalisme qui permettra de régler
le problème c'est avec l'amour coup qu
on règle tous les problèmes
c'est pas avec la haine les islamistes
les les extrémistes et ce qu'ils
cherchent
qu'ils soient de tous bords donc là il
faut rester quand même bien bien centrer
voilà je vous le disais dans les titres
il y a un instant sur le plan de la
lutte contre la pandémie
les agences régionales de santé mène une
nouvelle expérimentation en région et
notamment en occitanie vous allez le
voir aux 400 mille tests antigénique ont
été pratiquées si la méthode est la même
que les tests pcr que vous connaissez à
présent ceux qui font un petit peu mal
au nez et bien les résultats sont
beaucoup plus rapides
avec ces nouveaux tests il s'affiche en
seulement 15 minutes
voici un premier bilan dans l'hérault
avec ce reportage réalisé par les
équipes de vie en occitanie sur place
une nouvelle forme de test kovy
d'expérimenter en occitanie 400 mille
tests antigénique sont déployés à
travers la région
il s'agit d'un prélèvement nasopharyngé
dont les résultats se développe au bout
de 15 minutes comme un test de grossesse
le principe réaliser des tests massif
auprès de personnes qui n'ont pas encore
déclarée de symptômes
le test est pour l'instant effectué dans
les universités les hôpitaux comme ici
dans cette maison de retraite qui a
répondu à l'appel à candidatures lancé
par l' agence régionale de santé
c'est un premier test qui nous permet de
faire des gens
après un premier tri sur les suspicions
voilà qui nous permet nous de savoir
très rapidement si on doit évincer un
salarié qui est potentiellement
contaminés si on va mettre en isolement
un résident voilà au lieu d'attendre
comme avant à peu près 24 heures voire
deux fois quarante huit heures voilà
avant d'avoir un résultat en cas de
positivité
on préfère faire un deuxième pcr en
laboratoire pour vraiment confirmer sa
positivité voilà certains d'entre vous
sont peut-être en vacances de toussaint
en tout cas certains d'entre vous ont
pris le chemin du littoral des hauts de
france
l'occasion de prendre un grand bol d'air
de se changer les idées avec le port du
masque c'est difficile d'oublier
totalement la crise sanitaire au touquet
vous allez voir une interdiction de
rassemblement nocturne a été instauré
une façon de ne pas réitérer les erreurs
de cet été avec des clusters d'étudiants
justement quelle est l'ambiance dans la
station dite des quatre saisons et bien
ceccaroli fichten de jouer ou la chaîne
de la voix du nord qui si on regarde de
la lumière un petit bleu et 13 degrés
sur le marché du touquet malgré le
masque il souffle un petit air de
vacances dans la station des quatre
saisons des allées sont parfois un peu
clairsemé mais la plupart des
commerçants sont confiants pour
l'affluence à venir lors d'un petit peu
plus de monde on sent bien que
les clients quittent les grandes villes
des grandes agglomérations pour profiter
voilà deux semaines ici au touquet le
fait beau puis les gens ils sont
contents d'être il ya de la place pour
tout le monde il avait le plein en plein
air tout ça il ya de la place ils ont
pas peur comme dans les villes ont passé
tous à l'art mais sinon regardez il ya
du monde les gens et se promène dans la
rue saint-jean toute proche les
restaurants ne font pas le plein loin de
là il compte sur une météo clémente qui
incitera les gens à sortir la première
semaine est toujours plus ou moins calme
mais là c'est un peu un peu moins que
d'habitude on ne reste confiant on a ce
que quand même on marche aussi avec le
soleil là on a dansé une belle semaine
ensoleillée donc je pense que et les
gens vont se déplacer un peu les gens se
déplaceront sûrement ne serait ce que
pour aller à la plage comme jules et
clémence tout juste arrivé de région
parisienne pour les vacances et qui
profite d'un bon bol d'air pas un
sourire une famille des crevettes à midi
levy est riche de plaisirs simples
dans ce journal nous prenons maintenant
le chemin des vosges d'epinal plus
précisément vous savez la filière
textile française a subi les remous de
la crise sanitaire notamment sur la
gestion de la commande publique
concernant les masques et malgré tout
certaines entreprises ont besoin
d'embaucher pour répondre à la demande
n'est pas le faire faute de personnel
qualifié des visites à destination de
demandeurs d'emploi sont ainsi organisés
comme l'illustrent ce reportage que vous
allez voir des équipes de via vosges au
coeur d'un atelier à epinal des petites
souris cartoonesque parfaitement
reconnaissable sur des masques qui vont
être utilisés dans un parc d'attractions
bien connu nous sommes chez atb à epinal
une jeune pme dont la moitié de
l'activité réside dans la confection et
la vente sur commande de masques
personnalisable
l'entreprise emploie 17 salariés à ce
jour et va se développer et donc
embaucher ou former de futurs
collaborateurs ce qui n'est pas simple
par les temps qui courent la confection
confection
il n'y a plus beaucoup d'entreprises
dans les jo ce qu'ils en font tout a été
délocalisée il ya maintenant il n'y a
plus d'une centaine d'années donc mine
de rien en vingt ans sans exercer ce
métier est toujours par vagues et s'est
jamais dès ce soir même si jamais
régulier aujourd'hui c'est vrai que l'on
constate une recrudescence des besoins
d'opérateurs en confection qu'on n'avait
pas eu encore un an un an et demi aux
alentours d'une trentaine d'opérateurs
confection sur le département à ce jour
nullement à mettre en adéquation l'offre
et la demande c'est tout l'objet des
cinq visites organisées tout au long de
la semaine par boschker textile à
destination de demandeurs d'emploi
intéressés par ce secteur d'activité
comme hélène qui aspire un devenir
confectionneuse j'ai découvert la tuerie
a pas longtemps donc grâce aux ateliers
d'affaires sombre du secours catholique
est en fait sa mue comme une passion en
fait donc j'ai vécu t'adorer j'aime bien
je suis patiente enfin j'aime bien c'est
juste une question de passion en fait et
je voudrais continuer dans l'été là
parce que vous mettiez à la base c'était
le ménage
un profil qui pourrait intéresser ce
jeune chef d'entreprise dans un secteur
dont le maître mot est désormais
adaptation ici ont fabriqué
exclusivement des tabliers il ya encore
deux ans les masques 10000 par semaine
occupe désormais la moitié de la
production pour des clients tous issus
du secteur privé la commande publique
ayant ici comme ailleurs lâché en rase
campagne
les entreprises textiles française était
scandaleuse pour nous parce qu'au début
on nous a demandé qu'il faut fabriquer
des masques ont été tout le monde au
travail il faut investir pour acheter
des machines on nous a dit mais surtout
ne vendait pas aux entreprises garder
les masques pour nous pour l'état on va
vous passer des commandes est en fait en
parallèle ils savaient ils cherchaient
des alternatives ailleurs ils ont passé
des commandes un peu partout en asie
notamment beaucoup au vietnam
sachant que la parenthèse masque se
refermera forcément un jour pour la
branche textile qui a bien d'autres
défis à relever comme ceux du
renouvellement des générations et
surtout de la relocalisation
cette jeune entreprise spinalienne
entend ainsi contribuer à rapatrier en
france la production des tabliers de
trappes place maintenant dans ce journal
à notre rubrique écorégions nous allons
cette semaine mettre à l'honneur une
entreprise française qui a réussi à
lever pas moins de 90 millions de
dollars pour accélérer son développement
à l'international depuis le nord de la
france bonjour michel picaud exo tech
c'est le nom de cette entreprise qui est
elle comment ont-ils a réussi cet
exploit
bonjour cyril bonjour à toutes et à tous
oui exo tech est basée à croix dans le
nord de la france et l'entreprise
fabrique des robots qui prépare les
commandes dans les grands entrepôts des
gros sites e-marchands internet
ils ont créé l'entreprise en 2015 à
l'époque leur robot n'avait d'ailleurs
pas totalement prouvé sa capacité mais
un géant de la vente en ligne basé à
bordeaux a fait confiance à ses jeunes
ingénieurs
le groupe passe alors comment tu et puis
tout s'emballe
les robots sont réellement exceptionnel
et les commandes arrivent d'un peu
partout dans le monde
il faut donc produire plus les créateurs
de l'entreprise font alors le choix
audacieux de rester à croix dans le nord
de la france pour y créer leurs propres
usines
le développement international est basé
sur la production sur place ce qui lui
développe à l'international et bien et
où sera produit à l'international car le
coût de transport de ces robots est très
lourd en revanche l'usiné de croix qui
existe et qui est une usine ultramoderne
lusine 4.0 elle permet de réduire les
coûts de production et de servir tout le
monde aujourd'hui et à terme uniquement
le marché européen depuis le nord de la
france un petit mot côté emploi ils sont
passés de 5 salariés en 2015 à 100 en
2019 et il prévoit d'embaucher
aujourd'hui 250 personnes dans les mois
qui viennent grâce à cette levée de
fonds exceptionnel de 80
millions de dollars ils veulent partir à
la conquête du monde et ironie de
l'histoire au pays où les robots sont
rois le japon et bien ce sont les robots
français d'exo tech qui équipe les
entrepôts du plus grand distributeur de
vêtements là bas que retenir de cette
histoire que c'est un site internet
français qui a fait confiance à une
pépite du nord qui lui a permis de
devenir une grande entreprise ambitieuse
ensemble on est et on sera effectivement
plus fort dans le territoire
effectivement très intéressant merci
michel picaud et à très vite
tous en selle maintenant nous partons à
nantes métropole nantaise où le vélo a
supplanté la voiture dans la ville
pas n'importe quel bicyclette d'ailleurs
c'est un véritable phénomène auquel nous
sommes intéressés vous allez le voir le
vélo cargo qui vous permet d'amener vos
enfants à l'école ou de faire vos
courses vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage de télénantes les fabricants
sont tout simplement débordé il
s'apprête à vivre une fin d'année record
aymeric et son entreprise viennent de
remporter le marché des triporteurs en
libre service parisien 120 unités a
livré avant la fin d'année et un carnet
de commandes qui se remplit en parallèle
le marché pour les collectivités et les
entreprises a littéralement explosé ces
derniers mois on a de plus en plus de
commandes de collectivités pour ses
clips ont leurs agents que ce soit de la
propre vie urbaine des espaces verts de
la logistique etc
la difficulté est désormais de trouver
certains composants une pénurie a pointé
son nez à la sortie du confinement côté
main d'oeuvre après huit premières
années difficiles avec un marché qui ne
décollait pas leur est désormais aux
embauches pour renforcer l'équipe de
quatre salariés on actuellement
de nouveaux intérimaires qui sont là
depuis quelques semaines qu'ils étaient
avant d'en
dans l'aéronautique c'est vrai le
malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres
on avait beaucoup de mal à recruter en
fait des talents jusqu'à présent
effectivement avec avec les difficultés
que rencontrent aéronautique
actuellement et bien nous nous avons la
chance de pouvoir trouver des des
talents donc disponible immédiatement
pour venir renforcer nos équipes
la marque d'origine danoise conçoit
aussi des triporteurs pour les familles
la majorité des pièces sont fabriquées
dans la région le produit haut de gamme
reste cher plus de 2500 euros
si la demande des particuliers est aussi
en hausse beaucoup se tournent vers des
commandes sur internet avec des modèles
venus d'asie presque deux fois moins
cher pour autant c'est une belle
croissance qui attendent entreprises
elle prépare même l'extension de ses
locaux à couëron voilà elle s'appelle
lamy et c'est une application qui
protège les piétons aller tester
actuellement dans les yvelines vous
allez le voir
développé par la ratp est une start-up
l'application pour but de prévenir les
piétons trop distraits par leur
smartphone et qui s'apprête à traverser
la rue on en a tous croisé bien sûr vous
êtes peut-être connu d'ailleurs dans ce
portrait plus de détails avec nos
confrères de tv 78 exilés et mis un
dispositif pour protéger les piétons
pour l'heure sous forme d'application il
permet d'alerter les utilisateurs qui
s'apprête à traverser au feu rouge
une solution qui s'adresse surtout aux
smoby récement bis un nouveau mot c'est
la contraction de smartphones et zombies
pourquoi ce monde vivent à ce qu'on sent
les zombies quand et sur un téléphone
dans la rue on est tous à un moment
bascons en train de rechercher notre
itinéraire parce qu'on regarde nos mails
et qu'on est pressé et maintenant on est
tellement absorbé par son téléphone on
fait plus attention danger qui nous
entourent notamment quand ils traversent
une application qui utilise la
technologie des ultrasons le programme
envoie une alerte sur le téléphone en
cas d'inattention ou de danger
quand vous avez téléchargé l'application
et que vous activer la fonctionnalité
amis en fait si vous vous apprêtez à
traverser la route alors que le feu est
rouge vous allez recevoir une alerte sur
un téléphone au relais retrait de
plusieurs types
ça peut être une alerte sonore ici on a
choisi le bruit d'un klaxon voiture
c'est assez surprenant quand vous êtes
sur votre téléphone
une vibration et un message visite
l attention le feu est rouge dans les
yvelines le dispositif a déjà été
implanté à vélizy-villacoublay sa rémy
les chevreuse et mantes la jolie
ici à saint quentin en yvelines de
traversées piétonnes ont été équipés au
croisement de l'avenue du centre et de
l'avenue gustave eiffel un emplacement
stratégique
il ya un point de passage qui mène du
centre commercial à la gare aux
nombreuses entreprises du secteur du
quartier est également de l'université
de versailles saint quentin qui est
derrière juste à côté donc à toute heure
du jour principalement il ya un flux de
passage en courant continu pour l'heure
encore en expérimentation la
fonctionnalité pourrait par la suite se
retrouver dans des applications telles
que celle de la ratp
whatsapp deezer ou encore spotify
voilà prenant le large pour nous la mère
maintenant dans ce grand jt des
territoires pour aller rencontrer
françois gabart le célèbre skipper qui a
ouvert à concarneau en bretagne son
entreprise un an après la pose de sa
première pierre le bâtiment fourmis
d'une cinquantaine de salariés vous
allez le voir affairés à la construction
du dernier né du petit prince des mers
visite guidée par nos confrères de tv au
la chaîne des télégrammes en mode on
avance le cockpit juste code m101 maxi
trimaran de 32 mètres par 23 futurs
pensionnaires de la classe ultime donc
conçu et fabriqué en partie par françois
gabart et son équipe à concarneau le
nouvel oiseau des mers innove notamment
au niveau de la cellule de vie on la met
au milieu alors un peu derrière le
un peu derrière le mas n'ont pas aussi
avancée que sur sodebo néanmoins plus
avancé que ce qu'on avait sur le bateau
le bateau l'ancien bateau est par contre
surtout cette zone de vie elle est
vraiment intégré complètement dans la
coque centrale dans l'objectif de
d'avoir une aéro enfin pénétration dans
l'air la meilleure possible à tout vol
aujourd'hui donc les héros est
fondamentale et l'idée c'est de pouvoir
intégrer un maximum de personnes d'être
plus protégés possible et d'être dans
des conditions de navigation à des
vitesses élevées plus confortable et
sécurisé impossible d'en savoir
davantage pour l'heure sur les
appendices sujet de performances
fondamentales de ces bateaux la mise à
l'eau elle est programmée pour juin 2021
avec un premier gros défi en vue on a
deux mois d'essai en mer la recette
définitif la finalisation de la
construction du bateau quelque part et
au bout des deux mois dans fin 2021
ensuite on se prépare nous à faire un
tour du monde en équipage pas en
solitaire ça c'est absolument impossible
à faire quelques mois après la mise à
l'eau d'un bateau comme ça néanmoins
c'est dans cette démarche là qu'on est
d'ici là le prodige de trégunc devrait
annoncer son nouveau partenaire il se
dit très confiant à ce sujet celui ci
devrait le voir s'élancer en solitaire
cette fois pour la prochaine du rhum sur
m101 rebaptisé naviguer faire voler les
gens voient l'appui dans l'actualité des
cris de terreur à maizières-lès-metz du
mercredi au dimanche et ce jusqu'au 1er
novembre ou alligator c'est un parc
d'attractions célèbre halloween pour
faire trembler de peur le public les 42
hectares du parc ont été mis à mort
faisait entre créatures terrifiantes
attraction sort ce lait et manoir hanté
les frissons garantis
la preuve avec ce reportage de fanny
bragard moselle tv sur place regarde
depuis 20 ans pour halloween
le parc walygator joue à faire peur
décoration effrayante animations
flippante l'attraction terrifiante et
attendent les visiteurs
une position gagnante puisque
d'ordinaire le mois d'octobre représente
15 % de la fréquentation annuelle du
parc dans cette période morose si on
peut dans un espace non confiné avec un
protocole sanitaire important donner
envie aux gens de se divertir de changer
de les idées on en profite et on a 150
salariés qui sont là et qui met entre y
met le paquet et les citrouilles pour
faire en sorte que les gens passent une
journée inoubliable
vingt tonnes de citrouilles des
kilomètres de toile d'araignée des
créatures d'outre-tombe donne une
coloration inquiétante au parc c'est
vraiment un beau parc déjà en temps
normal
et là je sais que tous les ans ils font
un travail extraordinaire
alors j'ai décidé de moi même me
déplacer et je confirme que c'est un
travail vraiment explosive
pour faire frissonner de peur et de
plaisir ses visiteurs l'équipe du parc a
prévu des animations spectaculaires
comme ce numéro d'évasion ou divina n'a
qu'une minute pour s'échapper avant qu
une mâchoire en acier ne se referme sur
elle il ya de tout ça qu'on a des
artistes en déambulation qui vont aller
au contact bien sûr du visiteur en
créant des l'émotion du rire de la peur
avec différents personnages et après on
a des animations très très courte c'est
à dire moins cinq minutes l'idée est de
faire vivre le parc walygator dans toute
sa splendeur et surtout dans toute sa
grandeur on veut qu'il y ait des
spectacles et des animations partout et
que les gens puissent s'amuser
absolument partout dans le parc
sensations garanties pour les visiteurs
plonger dans l'ambiance d'halloween aux
quatre coins du parc les hurlements
résonne la république pour après avec
d'être au ce2 le décor il est super bien
mais il est bien en thème d'halloween
oui eh bah elles l'émanation toujours
aussi bien et sensationnel pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas se faire peur l'équipe a
prévu des badges gentil monstre qui
tiendront à distance tous ces êtres
horrifique elle les visiteurs les plus
téméraires ne seront pas épargnés s'ils
ont le courage de pénétrer dans l'asile
il risque de ne pas en sortir indemne
pour prolonger le plaisir de soirée
mortels sont prévues les 24 et 31
octobre
direction la sorte à présent à l'école
des apprentis sorciers vous allez voir
le magasin sweets dédié à l'univers la
saga harry potter a ouvert ses portes
un concept qui ne propose que des
produits sur l'apprenti sorcier harry
potter un phénomène de mode qui entrent
aussi dans l'école vous allez le voir
une enseignante du sud-sarthe d'ailleurs
à transformer sa classe en poudlard et
toute l'année les élèves de grande
section et de cp apprennent en compagnie
du sorcier lui-même
embarquement immédiat avec les équipes
de lmtv sartre sur place
à court de manche la professeur des
écoles est aussi magicienne ici harry
potter donne des cours de mathématiques
font face et en sport on joue au
quidditch
c'est vraiment les premiers livres qui
m'ont fait aimer la lecture et du coup
l'univers fantastique et magique ça me
plaît vraiment et j'essaye de
transporter les enfants dans cet univers
pour ans les apprentissages un petit peu
plus drôle et plus fun pour y avait une
inspectrice quand j'ai commencé qui
disait toujours pour les enfants pour
qu'ils apprennent il faut que ce soit
grand beau et joyeux et je pense que là
j'y suis j'espère en tout cas un concept
pédagogique qui a demandé à
l'enseignante plusieurs mois de travail
et le petit sorcier n'est pas là que
pour faire découvrir la lecture aux
écoliers l'apprentissage passe beaucoup
mieux par le jeu et donc ils apprennent
beaucoup mieux sans s'en rendre compte
en fait là les mathématiques avec harry
potter par exemple ils ont travaillé
l'espace donc le repérage de spécial au
dessus ou en dessous sans s'en rendre
compte
avant chaque vacance scolaire comme dans
la saga un banquet est organisée pour
connaître le vainqueur de la coupe des
quatre maisons débit dans leur petit
vase pour que soient aussi visuel pour
eux parce qu'on a on arrive dans les 275
c'est un petit peu abstrait pour eu
encore et donc ils devront un cadeau à
gagner avant chaque vacances et les
premiers auront un très gros cadeau et
il devient un petit peu moins gros faire
à mesure qu'on descend mais ils ont
comme tous quelque chose
alors qui de gryffondor serpentard
poufsouffle ou serdaigle remportera la
coupe pour ce début d'année
réponse ce vendredi à l'école poudlard
de courdemanges
voilà pourra rire et ce journal nous
partons à la découverte de notre
patrimoine maintenant direction la corse
bâti sur un piton rocheux voici le
village de speloncato deux églises
paroissiales rythme la vie quotidienne
de ce village de nombreux monuments
chargés d'histoire sont à découvrir en
ce moment grâce aux actions menées par
l'office du tourisme de l'île rousse
balagne voici un avant-goût par les
équipes devient telle est pas aisé
regarder
[Musique]
et
c'est un village qui a une forte
histoire j'ai beaucoup apprécié cet
échange avec les confrères effectivement
je crois que il essaye de perpétuer une
histoire est quelque chose qui est bien
ancré ici ça m'a beaucoup rapprochés de
leurs idées en tout cas que vous inspire
le village de speloncato ça a l'air très
axé sur la religion donc c'est il ya
beaucoup de belles si c'est vraiment
très intéressant je m'attendais pas à
voir autant de deux cultures et deux
monuments groupes locaux tout est un
très beau village connu en balagne pour
sa richesse patrimoniale richesse aussi
au niveau du patrimoine religieux mais
c'est surtout que c'est un village
construit je dirais sur des pièges
voilà avec deux paroisses donc la pierre
et de s'entendre y avait de tout gagner
avec aussi une partie village dans la
vallée c'est une visite d'exception qui
a été mise en place par l'office
il ya une volonté de mettre en valeur
ses patrimoine rural c'est surtout pour
contrecarrer aussi cette image de
tourisme de masse que l'on peut avoir
c'est de créer quelque chose
si vous voulez en lien social c'est un
tourisme culturel que l'on développe
dans le rural
c'est important pour nous de participer
à cette visite parce que justement est
là pour transmettre la confrérie
c'est la gardienne du patrimoine donc
c'est bien beau de garder le patrimoine
mais c'est pour justement pour le
transmettre
et aussi s'ouvrir sur l'extérieur elles
nous ont raconté ce qu'on aime notre
histoire ce qu'on est ce qu'on fait et
ce qu'on apporte au village voilà depuis
signalons dans les médias des
territoires cette semaine l'initiative
de nos confrères de nice matin
comment ces mères propulsé au coeur du
drame ont-ils géré l'urgence
quelles sont leurs doutes et leurs
espoirs au lendemain du passage de la
tempête alex qui a fait de nombreuses
victimes et de très gros dégâts et quels
enseignements selon eux doit-on tirer de
cette catastrophe et bien nice matin a
décidé de produire ce reportage ce
documentaire est de partir à la
rencontre de ces élus du haut pays pour
recueillir les témoignages de cinq
d'entre eux leur récit est à retrouver
dans ce documentaire donc produit par
les équipes de nice matin
alex les maires face à la tempête
vous pouvez donc retrouver sur le site
internet de nice matin
c'est même pas une crue centenaire à
laquelle nous avons assisté c'est pire
que ça
la peur concrètement
[Musique]
me suis rendu compte que quand le joueur
allait se lever on allait voir vraiment
un paysage la pop airbus voit la fin de
bus grands dicter des territoires sur
vos chaînes locales et régionales et sur
tv5 monde et en ayant bien sûr pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]